sticking with Yahoo I want to also talk
to you about allegations that Yahoo CEO
Marissa Mayer purged male workers Meyer
melissa meyer man I just I cannot get
that right Melissa Meyer Marissa Meyer
most of my Marissa Meyer Marissa Meyer
yes I think I got it now right we'll
start over now just kidding we're gonna
keep going there's a lawsuit alleging a
Scott ardh was a media executive who was
fired from Yahoo last year and he's
filed a lawsuit accusing CEO Marissa
Mayer of leading a campaign to get rid
of male workers okay the lawsuit says
that Meyer encouraged and Foster using
an internal performance rating system
that yahoo had to accommodate the
subjective biases of Management which
Scott ardh alleges were to get rid of
men and to bring in women and ARDS
lawsuit also says that yahoo illegally
fired large numbers of workers through a
system imposed by Mayer so let's look at
a quote here I want to start with this
this is from the Scott art lawsuit
against Yahoo when Savitt began at Yahoo
the top managers reporting to her
including the chief editors of the
verticals and magazines were less than
20% female within a year and a half
those top managers were more than 80%
female Savitt has publicly expressed
support for increasing the number of
women in media and has intentionally
hired and promoted women because of
their gender while terminating demoting
or laying off male employees because of
their gender of the approximately 16
senior level editorial employees hired
or promoted by savat in approximately an
18-month period fourteen of them or 87
percent were female now yahoo
categorically denies the allegations
when I heard this I initially thought
this is just the old boys club swinging
the other way and ballast balancing
things out but that is not what the
allegations are at all the allegations
accused that Yahoo fired senior
editorial staff and basically replace
them with women to go from 20% female to
80% female in 18 months in addition this
is not the first lawsuit of its kind
against Yahoo now we're altima to sort
out what happened I really have a
problem
with people calling this reverse sexism
if it is true that's a term that gets
thrown around sexism is sexism right if
you are making fires and hires merely on
the basis of gender that is just sexism
this idea a reverse doesn't make sense
to me now
many people on opposing sides are
furious here I'm getting emails from the
anti feminists and the so-called men's
rights activists they're saying David
you're not you probably but many people
are not taking this seriously because
it's about men rather than women if it
was reversed if someone came in and
fired the women and hired men it would
be front page news on all corporate
media but there's also another side
where I have feminists angry because
they say nobody should be mad here this
is just evening the playing field and
why would anybody be mad well if the
lawsuit is is accurate 80% women by
firing men that were already there
that's not exactly leveling the playing
field so we're going to follow this and
see where it ends up the allegations are
incredibly serious and I listen social
justice warrior men's rights activists
all these terms that get thrown around
I'm a progressive I'm not going to
ignore the story because it appears that
gender was used as a basis for firing
and hiring it doesn't matter to me
whether it's men being fired or hired or
women being fired or hired if this is
going on I am going to report on it
I already have and keep all of the the
buzzwords to yourselves because they
really have no place here I'm covering
the story and I'll continue to follow it